Pablo escobar was the world's most successful drug trafficker.
He was also,
it's nice deadly.
During his 17 year reign at the top of the Colombian cocaine and bar,
he ordered the killings of thousands of people,
including judges,
ministers of parliaments,
and even presidential candidates.
At the height of his power,
he was raking in over a million dollars a day.
Yes,
in the end,
he was forced to live as a fugitive in the Colombian jungle.
Shut down on a rooftop in the city that he ruled over.
His was an epic fall from grace and this episode of biographics we go deep into
the south.
American drug dwells to reveal the true life of Don Pablo
Pablo Emilio Escobar.
Gaviria was born on December the first 1949 in the small town.
Every now grow 45 minutes from Midian.
Colombia,
his father able was a hardworking,
humble cattle farmer.
One his mother,
her Milda was a school teacher public.
The seconds of seven children was raised in a middle class environment and a
community that was fueled by the cocaine and marijuana trade.
Although not everyone's directly participated in the drug business.
They all had a powerful incentive in the protection of those that did the
violence.
That was part and parcel of enforcing the narcotic straight with all around
them.
Before starting school,
the family moved to end avocado,
a small village just outside of [inaudible] so that her Milda could establish an
elementary school that Abel sold the farm and took up a job as a neighborhood to
watch man through hard work at the school.
Her milled,
it soon became a popular and well respected member of the community at school.
Pablo proved himself to be enabled and quick witted students,
although tending toward the Chubby side,
thanks to his love of fast food,
he was talented in all ball sports with a special love for soccer.
Many of us teachers were involved in social causes,
especially the struggle for classic quality and they became very powerful
influences on the young Pablo.
By the time he was in his early teens public was attending street rallies and
participating in such activities like throwing rocks at the police probably
became part of a youth culture movement known as an a day Smoot,
which encouraged young people to thumb their noses at the established order they
were to do things like disobey their parents and write their own rules.
Part of this counter cultural movements involved experimentation with drugs
leading the 13 year old future drug kingpin to develop an addiction to
marijuana,
which would never leave him.
Okay.
By the age of 16 Pablo had developed into a plumper shorter youth standing just
over five foot six inches.
He had a round face and what a slight mustache.
A couple of before reaching his 17th birthday,
he dropped out of school board with the straight laced routine and keen to make
his own way in the wells.
After quitting school,
the enterprising pab lobe started up a bicycle repair shop.
He would prowl the streets,
sends the local dump in search of discarded bicycle parts and then use them to
fix bikes are cheap with the money that he made from this enterprise.
He purchased himself a Lambretta motorcycle.
Now with a means of foster escape,
he began planning how to make more money more easily than the by repairing
bicycles for a pittance.
According to legends,
Pablo Foray into crime began with him stealing headstones from the local
cemetery sounds,
blasting the names from them and then reselling them.
Pablo then decided though that the root to quick cash lay in commercial business
rubbery.
He started by scoping out potential targets.
He would then ride to the target business on his motorbike,
set Abella cover over his head and rush to the business with a knife or a gun in
hand,
demanding money,
and then be got out of that.
All of this would happen in about 30 seconds.
Well,
after a few successful robberies populate,
recruited his cousin to join him.
One would ride the bike and act as the getaway writer while the other stormed
into the business.
But within a few months,
patty,
they became bored of this and moved onto bigger and it's easier things.
He established a contact with a rent,
a car dealership.
He would provide him with copies of the keys to cars that he had just sold along
with the addresses of the buyers.
All the Pablo had to do was turn up at the address and drive the cars away.
In his late teens,
they public got caught in the act of stealing one of these cars.
He ended up spending several months in Lala Dara jail,
which was to him a very positive life experience.
It was in this jail cause he learns how to move into bigger criminal activity,
including kidnapping,
drug trafficking.
One SPEC on the street,
Pablo and his cousin,
Gustavo,
went right back to stealing costs.
They built up a collection of stolen engine parts,
which they would sell off bit by bit.
The bear then took to building race cars with Pablo competing in local events.
Pablo Ans Garcia weren't the only ones stealing cars in metagene though,
which led to an extension of his operation.
He decided to also sell protection so the people would pay him to ensure that
their car did not get taken.
Ballet was able to provide such a service because he had developed a reputation
as an unpredictable and violence young man.
If anyone who didn't money probably would hire a local thug,
do you kidnap that person?
He would then ransom him for whatever was owed to him from time to time.
He would even have that person kills when the ransom was paid simply to engender
fear in those he dealt with before long paddlow decided to specialize in
kidnappings for their own sake,
along with his cousin and future brother in law.
He nabbed a rich businessman by the name of Diego Acca Varia.
This man was intensely disliked by many of the poor workers in Midian.
He were being laid off droves by industrialists like him despite the family.
Okay.
In the $50,000 ransom demands.
Echo varia was beaten,
strangles and then dumped in a ditch even though he had just committed a
terrible crime.
His choice of victim made Pablo hugely popular.
Among the common folk have met a yin in a strange way.
They saw the killings as public striking a blow for social equality.
Sorry.
In 1971 the 22 year old Pavlo began working for [inaudible] based Contraband
Dealer Alvara Prieto underappreciated.
Pablo was doing a modest amount of drug trafficking before long.
However,
he decided that he wanted more of a slice of the pie for himself.
He drove his stolen running four to Ecuador and bought five kilograms of
Peruvian cocaine paste successfully passing through a number of police and
military checkpoints.
He returned to Midian where he processed the cocaine.
He next contacted fellow criminals.
The Ochoa brothers just set up a sale to a local cocaine chief called fattier
Restrepo.
The sale netted Pavlo close to $100,000 far surpassing anything he had
previously done and setting himself up firmly on the path to becoming a high end
drug dealer within two months.
February Restrepo had been murdered.
Suddenly there was a new man of the head of the [inaudible] cocaine operation,
and that was Pablo Escobar.
Now importantly,
it has never been conclusively proven.
The Pablo murdered Restrepo,
but that was what everyone involved believed.
The majority of people working for Restrepo were upper class dandies.
They were pretty frightened by Pablo and the ruthless hoodlums that he
surrounded himself with.
Shortly after muscling his way to the top of the median,
cocaine's indicas.
Pablo married 15 year old Maria,
Victoria,
Helena Vallejo,
so now Pablo,
he was 26 years old.
He had a wife,
he had wealth and he had power.
It really seems like the sky was going to be the limit.
The cocaine trade from Panama through Columbia and into the United States boomed
in the late 1970s with most of it being trafficked through Escobar's
organization under pablet with the cocaine industry became streamlined.
He purchased a fleet of airplanes including a Leer jet transport the drugs into
the United States where there was an inexhaustible supply of willing buyers.
Two months after his wedding though Pablo and four others were arrested,
resounding from a drug run to Ecuador,
drug enforcement agents founds 39 kilos of cocaine isn't in the spare tire of
their truck.
Vast amounts of coke would see Pablo put away for a long,
long time.
His first tactic and getting out of the mess was to bribe the trial judge.
The offer,
however,
was flatly rejected.
How beloved then had his team recently,
the judges backgrounds,
they discovered that he had a brother who was a lawyer and that the two men did
not get on.
The lawyer was contacted and offered a huge amounts to represent Pablo in the
case.
As suspected,
the judge was forced to recuse himself due to the conflict of interest and the
new judge.
Well,
he had less scruples about taking the payments.
He accepted the bribe and Pablo and his cohorts walked free.
Exorbitant amounts of money.
We're now pouring into Colombia with deposits in the countries.
Four major banks doubling between 1976 and 1980 [inaudible] was then able to use
his millions to take possession of every step of his operation.
Traveling to Peru,
Bolivia,
and it's Panama,
and buying up all the cultivation farms and processing plants.
He was also able to buy off enforcement agencies in every country developing a
ruthless policy which came to be known as silver or led.
If officials didn't accept his bribe,
they could expect to end up debt.
By 1980 Pablo was at the absolute height of his power with every law enforcement
agency on his payroll.
He was the unofficial king of Midian.
He wasn't the only cocaine,
Impresario and Columbia,
but he certainly was the most successful.
He owns multiple mansions.
He had racing cars,
helicopters and planes,
and was constantly surrounded by bodyguards and hangers on cocaine.
Money absolutely transformed many in with discos and high and restaurants
opening up all over the city.
One of paddleloons passions was soccer and now he was able to indulge it.
He paid to have fields levels and sorted and lights installed so that he and his
crew could play at nighttime.
He also employed professional game callers to announce the matches as if they
were an FAA Cup final in 1979 papillary wheels,
a lavish country estate.
On a 7,400 acre ranch,
80 miles outside of Midean and dws,
Hacienda Las and Apollos.
He brought exotic animals from all over the worlds to populate the farm,
built six swimming pools and a huge mansion that could sleep 100 guests at the
same time that he was indulging his every materialistic women private Pablo
began tending to his public image.
He constantly denied that he was involved in any illicit activity,
portraying a formal,
likable persona and appearing humble and polite.
He consciously cultivated the image that he was a freedom fighter for the
underprivileged,
setting himself up as an alternative to the establishment.
He also poured millions of dollars into social construction programs.
Between 1980 and 1982 Pablo did more to help the poor and meti in than the
Colombian government had ever done.
One of his most popular initiatives was a housing projects.
There was called Barrio Pablo Escobar,
where houses were bills,
and it's given us a families who had previously been sheltering in shacks.
The city dump this and a host of other projects easily made him the most popular
citizen in [inaudible] in private.
Pablo conducted himself in an understated manner.
He spoke softly and was generally relaxed and casual with the people around him.
He was also hugely self-indulgence with food,
with drink and with women,
and he considered himself a law unto himself.
As an example of this,
on one occasion when an employee was found to have stolen from him,
Pablo had him brought before him bound hand and first and then kicked it into
the swimming pool.
They can everyone watch as the man drowns
with his popularity among the masses firmly established and his dominance over
his empire assured.
The next logical step for Pablo was politics.
His path to and legitimate office began in 1978 when he was elected as a
substitute city counselor in met a year in 1980 he gave his personal and
financial support to the formation of a new national political movements,
the new Liberal Party.
Then in 1982 he ran for and was elected to Congress all the as a substitute who
attended when the primary delegate from that a yin was unavailable,
a major perk of being elected to Congress was that now Pablo had judicial
immunity,
meaning that he could not be convicted for any crime under Colombian law.
The position also afforded him a diplomatic visa,
which he made you solve to regularly take his family on trips to the United
States.
On one of these trips,
he purchased an $8 million mansion in Miami Beach,
Florida.
So public now had political legitimacy to go with his massive wealth.
And the next acquisition you made was a personal army,
one of friends of the family.
He was kidnapped by m 19 gorillas.
He created a private militia to hunt down these rebels.
Pablo Blues Army was known as death to kidnappers.
So Pablo is wider exposure as a result of his political office.
When it was the beginning of his downfall in Midian,
Pablo,
he was viewed as this Robin Hood figure,
but when he'd tried to gain the favor of polite Colombian society,
he was not welcomed.
They viewed him as what he really was a ruthless cocaine king with absolutely no
scruples when he turns up to take a seat in Congress as an alternate for the
first time on August the 16th 1983 with a bevy of bodyguards in tow,
he was first denied entry for not wearing a tie.
He quickly got hold of one and swept since the Pax Chamber.
He slumps down in his allocated seats and began nervously to bite his
fingernails.
Immediately the chamber president stood up and demanded that all body guards be
removed from the chamber.
Pablo nodded and just thugs left the room within minutes.
Justice Minister Rodrigo Lara was on his feet defending a claim of corruption
that had been brought against him.
Laura pointed his finger at Pablo and stated we have a congressman who was born
in a very poor area himself,
very,
very poor and afterwards through a stage of business,
deals in bicycles and other things.
Appears with a gigantic fortune with nine Blaine's three hangers at the media
unit airport and creates the movement death to kidnappers while on the other
hands,
mountains charitable organizations with which she tries to bribe a needy and
unprotected people.
Now there are investigations going in the United States of which I cannot inform
you here tonight in the House on the criminal conduct of Pablo Escobar.
Now,
Pablo said nothing in the house,
but when he left he was besieged by reporters breaking free.
He stormed off through his lawyer.
He informs Laura that if he did not present evidence of his claims within 24
hours,
he would face legal action.
Laura willingly obliged and then the coming days,
the newspapers were filled with all sorts of revelations about Pablos criminal
activity.
Pablo was now persona non grata in political circles.
He was kicked out of the new Liberal Party and theU s embassy revoked has
diplomatic visa.
The Catholic church also renounced their supportive and the governments even
seized 85 of the exotic animals on Pabla his ranch,
claiming that they had entered the country illegally.
Pablo,
his political career is now in ruins.
Even worse for Pablo be Colombian governments at Laura's urgings was fast
tracking an extradition treaty with the u s that would see him trying in America
for selling cocaine in that country.
In May of 1984 justice minister Lara was shot seven times while riding in his
chauffer driven limousine,
but Pablo had powerful enemies.
US President Ronald Reagan had announced a major crackdown on the cocaine trade
with the death of Laura.
The Colombian government were willing to cooperate with American authorities to
go after narco kingpins and Pablo.
He was the biggest of them all.
The killing of Lara also turns much of the Colombian population against Pavlay
by this act.
He had declared war on the state for Pablo.
The heat was too much to bear and he skip the country taking a helicopter to
Panama City.
Yet,
despite being offered asylum in Panama,
just the year before,
Pablo and his cronies were not welcomed by the authority.
After just a few weeks in exile Pablo,
he was desperate to get back home.
He made overtures to the Colombian government's drafting a proposal whereby he
would go straight and he uses massive influence to read Columbia of drug
trafficking,
provided that he could retain his possessions in Midian and that he would be
exempt from arrest or extradition to the United States.
There's other though it was roundly rejected when the Panamanian army rated one
of the labs that he had situated on the Colombian border.
He fled Panama for Nicaragua.
Meanwhile,
he was hearing that his absence from Columbia was undermining his control of the
median cartel,
the kidnapping of a 73 year old father.
Well,
that was a step too far.
Pablo audit,
a killing frenzy throughout in dozens of suspected kidnappers.
They would just gunned down.
Finally,
they gave in and Pablo,
his old man was released with no ransom ever being paid.
Okay.
In the midst of the carnage over his father's kidnapping,
Pablo returned to Columbia.
He was now determined to take on the state with everything that he had around
Medina.
He was untouchable having bought off every official.
This allows him,
although being the most wanted man in the country to move around the town
freely.
Public vengeful focus during the mid eighties was squarely centered on the
judiciary,
especially judges who supported the extradition treaty with the U s.
During this time,
more than 30 judges were shot dead.
Then in November of 1985 the gorilla grip,
I'm 19 having been paid $1 million by Pavlo,
stormed the palace of justice and how's the entire supreme court hostage.
They demanded that the government renounced the extradition treaty in the
resulting siege.
11 of the 24 justices along with 40 of the rebels were killed.
By the beginning of 1988 killings were being reported on an almost daily basis.
Martial law was declared to around the state from toppling.
On August the 18th 1989 pueblos kill squads gun down both the front running
presidential candidates,
Luis Galen,
and say state police chief.
In the following four months,
the Colombian government apprehended and sent more than 20 suspected drug
traffickers to the United States to stand trial and national police units with
stations to Metta Une specifically to hunt down Pablo.
Within the first month,
30 of the 200 men station there had been killed.
Pablo was evading as governments and inflicting enormous casualties,
but he was a man constantly on the run.
He always stayed a step ahead of his pursuers,
but he was growing tired of the constant relocations that were needed.
Eventually he was driven to negotiate.
Pablo agreed to put an end to all the violence to stop all criminal activity and
hand himself in.
In exchange,
he demands it preferential treatments in a prison of his choosing and a reduced
settlement.
The government had already revoked the extradition treaty to the U s with its
1991 constitution,
so he didn't have to worry about being sent to America and it's with all of
that.
Pablo was duly arrested and duty tried.
He began his sentence as low catty drought prison in June of 1991 but this,
well,
it was like no other prison on earth.
If featured a football pitch to QC and a bar,
all of the prison guards were pub Lowe's employees.
The prison cells were more like hotel suites and the food that Pablo and his
fellow inmates.
It was prepared by chefs who were brought in from the finest restaurants.
But after a few months,
accounts began to reach official channels that Pablo was continuing to pursue
his criminal activities from the prison.
This was a violation of the surrender agreements and to move as were put in
place to sees him and move him to a regular prison.
Pablos connections enabled him to get a wind of the plan and he escaped before
authorities.
It get to him,
okay,
Pablo is back on,
but now the u s and Colombian authorities were joins buying a vigilante group
known as the Los Padres,
which stood for people persecuted by Pablo Escobar.
Last pap has carried out a ruthless campaign,
killing as many as 300 people who were connected to Pablo and disorganization.
Following his escape.
Public was constantly on the run.
Most of his closest associates were dad and his organization was totally falling
apart.
He was spending nights sleeping in the jungle,
afraid to speak on the radio or even to answer the phone.
Finally,
they fake caught up with Pablo Escobar.
On December the second 1993 members of a Colombian search bloc team attracted
down to her house in Los Olivos in marine via radio intercepts.
The search bloc team smashed through the heavy steel door with a sledgehammer,
whereupon six of them rushed into the house.
It was then the shooting started with Pablo in the house was his most loyal
bodyguard known as Lehman.
They both bolted from the front room and made their way up into the roof.
The six search bloc members along with others outside port,
a massive barrage of gunfire at their targets.
Lemon was hit several times in the back and tumbled to the ground below.
Then Pablo went down.
He was struck several times in the leg and torso,
but the fatal shot penetrated his skull on confirming his targets.
The leader of the operation spoke excitedly into his radio viva like Columbia.
We have just killed Pablo Escobar,
but had they,
Pablo had always told his family that if cornered,
he would commit suicide by placing a bullet in his skull.
Many people believe that he did so one smaller escaping the clutches of the
Colombian authorities.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.